Surveys show that most people want to die
“quickly, in their sleep, and without notice”
but the odds of that happening for you are
incredibly low. So, when the time comes, how
are you most likely to die?
In 1901 the average life expectancy of humans
was 31 years old, and in just over 100 years
that average has gone up to 71. If you live
in a developed nation like France or Canada,
you’ll likely liver closer to 82, while
developing or majority world countries like
Rwanda age to 64 on average.
And many of these people die in weird ways,
including 27 people from selfie-related accidents
in 2015. One man died of heart failure and
exhaustion after playing Starcraft for 50
hours on end, and annually 100 people die
in Russia from falling icicles. Not to mention
about 70 children will choke to death on hot
dogs every year.
But if we use the United States as an example
of the western world, we had over 318 million
people living in 2014, of which more than
2.6 million died. Almost half of these people
died of heart disease or cancer, which is
much different than 100 years ago when most
people died from tuberculosis and influenza.
Scientific advancements such as antibiotics
and vaccines have allowed us to die less often
of the flu or TB, and even decreased how often
we die of cancer. In the 1970’s the survival
rate from cancer was only 50% - today that
has increased to 68% with 15.5 million cancer
survivors alive in the US today. Thanks SCIENCE!
Unfortunately both heart disease and cancer
aren’t ‘sudden killers’ and involve
mostly long, drawn out deaths. In fact, 60%
of deaths in hospital are attributed to one
of these, with 1 in 10 of those individuals
being in a hospital for a month or more. Of
course, sudden deaths do happen, with 136,053
people dying of unintentional injuries or
accidents in 2014, in the US.
The media can also affect our fear and anxiety
of death from strange causes. After all, not
one person died of a shark attack in the US
during 2014, but 38 people were killed by
dogs that year. Many fear biking within a
city, but you’re more likely to die walking
as a pedestrian, with 6,200 pedestrians killed,
and only 900 killed in bike accidents. For
every 1 person that dies in a terrorist attack,
80 will die from alcoholism.
In fact, a majority of terrorist activity
in the west is caused by lone wolf attackers,
of which 80% were not islamic fundamentalists,
but instead political extremists, nationalist,
racial and religious supremacists. On a worldwide
scale in 2015, 78% of all terrorists deaths
occurred in just five countries: Afghanistan,
Iraq, Nigeria, Pakistan and Syria.
Where you live has a big impact on how you’re
likely to die too; in the 34 poorest countries
you’re mostly likely to die of respiratory
problems - not from cigarettes, but from ingesting
smoke while cooking. Females in Japan are
less likely to die of heart disease, and live
to 87 years old on average, compared to 80
years old for American females. This is often
attributed to the Japanese diet.
In the future, we will likely not only live
longer, but potentially know exactly how and
when we’ll die. In fact, a recent computer
software has been developed that has been
shown to estimate how and when you will die
with 96% accuracy, based on medical history,
lifestyle and many other factors. The question
is - do you want to know how and when you’ll
die? Let us know in the comments below.
You can also find out the Top 5 Regrets People
Have Before Dying in our AsapTHOUGHT video.
Link in the description for that video.
And Subscribe for more weekly science videos!